advice from lillian vernon on the  entrepreneurial mindset as seen in zuga  triple zero  it's a quality you're born with being an  entrepreneur i'm a stick with it person  it's just my personality i never give up  it was a risk i had a husband and i was  pregnant with my oldest son but i don't  look at risk the way other people do  when you're an entrepreneur you have to  go in feeling like you're going to be  successful  i never gave up and i never let anyone  or anything get in my way i use my power  of positive thinking to tackle obstacles  and challenges so they don't defeat me  work hard that's the bottom line don't  spend more money than you've got don't  spend money before you've got it  believe in your dreams if you've done  the necessary financial analysis market  research and financial planning go for  it  to learn more check out zuga triple zero  in the link below